as we continue to celebrate national
women's history month the professional
women in building council is hoping to
attract more female students into the
industry now we spoke to one student who
tells us winning the scholarship helped
achieve her dream job
civil engineering itself is a lot of
math and a lot of people you get to talk
to a lot of people you have to
coordinate with absolutely everybody on
each of the designs gabrielle squilante
says it's been a year since she landed
her dream job at taney engineering but
getting there was no easy task my mom
told me no matter what you need to
intern and i was so frustrated because
everyone's getting a's on all these
exams and i was getting c's i didn't
have nearly the time to study and i am
so glad my mom told me to do that
because
the networking was huge today she can't
stop praising her mother who works in
the construction industry for telling
her about the professional women in
building council and the building hope
scholarship that she says winning helped
shape her career the women in pwb are
something else when it comes to support
i mean i can go to any of these women
and ask them probably pretty intense
questions too you know i don't know how
to navigate this kind of situation that
i'm in at work and i know that they'll
take it seriously the scholarship is
geared towards helping young women
financially to advance their education
and training in building industry
related fields to qualify applicants
must be a student at a college
university or trade school and pursuing
an education in a building-related
course of study or trait program simple
requirements this young engineer says is
helping her and other women play a vital
role in a male driven industry do not be
afraid to ask questions because there is
so much to learn
and there are so many people who are
incredibly supportive and are happy to
teach and i would say number two network